[Music]
my connection to the arts is music I
grew up singing in the church that's how
we communicate that's how we relate my
first memories of performance go back to
when I was in Pennsylvania growing up my
favorite thing was getting to be
theatrical to tell a story and I've
always brought that sort of narrative
element to my live shows I was just
obsessed with singing I was obsessed
with dancing but it started off with me
in the kitchen you know with with my
socks on trying to do the moonwalk and I
think that you need to choose something
that you're so obsessed with you just
want to do it all the time I was cast in
1981 just before we opened I snapped my
Achilles tendon and I thought that that
was my history with cats but it turns
out not to me
[Music]
when I first heard I was going to be in
cats instantly I felt the pressure this
musical is timeless
I just remembered loving it so when cats
became a movie obviously I had jumped at
the chance I think it could really only
be done by a director like Tom Hooper he
understands the spectacle of cats at the
center of this incredibly entertaining
comedic fantastical musical is a very
timely story about the importance of
inclusion and redemption I think it just
speaks really powerfully to everyone
there are so many emotions and we've got
to update it in ways that I think are
just so so so great I came right off of
a stadium tour and went right into
rehearsals from tomorrow I start to sing
my big number show business
[Music]
directing cats is like directing a group
of world-class athletes you politely
twins or possibly the most famous
hip-hop danced you
and Frankie Hayward is such a fine you
know it's one of the best starts in the
world as principal of the world ballet
my favorite part of ballet and dancing
is telling the story without words and
how you can say that with just your eyes
or your face or your body I think it's
amazing
[Music]
we also lucky enough to have Andy blank
computer who choreographed Hamilton when
you see people that are at the top of
their game doing it you raise your bar
as well people coming together through
all different corners of entertainment
you have some of the best hip hop
dancers Royal Ballet
some of the best tappers in a world
everybody's working really long hours of
cursing every day and it's fun the
designer lesense oh my god what is this
a so spectacular it's just so much fun
to play in the scale of this film is
huge three or four times bigger for the
cat perspective it's a massive
undertaking I kind of Alice in
Wonderland experience
Tom's pairing them with a kind of level
of technology which I don't think has
ever been used before we've used digital
fur technology to create the most
perfect covering 1/3 these are people
but they're cats and this is kind of
blowing my mind
there is nothing else like it this is a
moment for you to step into a world desk
completely designed to entertain me I
just was like really excited and so
honored to get to be a part of us this
film is an event
[Music]
you